i got c-level executives from  billion-dollar companies to get coffee  with me i decided i wanted to know more  rich people  like i just i wanted more rich friends i  should say successful successful friends  all my friends are my age so it's like  nobody's crazy successful or anything i  ended up calling these like major  executives i made a list of like 50  major executives in milwaukee i said i'm  23 years old  i want to know what it takes to be  successful i'm curious as to what you  have to say  i got some no's but i got more yeses  than you'd think i asked the executives  i said what percent of your success  would you say was talent and what  percent of your success would you say  was hard work  most of them told me something along the  lines of 30 talent  and 70 hard work the whole thing showed  me that  honestly people are so willing to help  you if you ask  none of them knew me none of them had to  spend time with me because i  asked they said yes